ça y est l'opéra bastille a trouvé son
directeur musical son chef d'orchestre
c'est la solution d'une crise qui avait
démarré au moment du licenciement de
daniel barenboim
le nouvel élu est un homme très peu
connue en france mais déjà très très
cotées à l'étranger
c'est un sud coréen ou non un petit peu
difficile à prononcer s'appelle disons
plus pour sa part les simplement mister
chung jean-claude d'arrigo à 7 ans il
jouait déjà en soliste au piano avec
l'orchestré philharmonique de séoul
il part ensuite en amérique et on le
retrouve en 1983 dirigeants en chef
invité les plus grands orchestres
européens berlin londres amsterdam
l'orchestré national de france et
l'orchestré de paris son expérience de
l'opéra il l'a acquise en italie au
metropolitan de new york et si son nom
n'est pas encore très connu du public
français
il est une valeur sûre j'évolue que que
l'homme qui allait venir et qui allait
s'investir dans cette aventure
incomparable qui pourra être offert à
bastille soit un homme jeunes compétents
et sérieux m'a semblé bien sûr il ya des
chefs très grand très célèbre et les
admire tout autant qu'un autre nom
généralisons pas le temps consacré
on l'a bien vu ailleurs et on l'avait
bien le programme du maestro chun à
l'opéra bastille nous le connaîtrons
progressivement dès l'automne durant ces
quelques mois il aura à mettre sur pied
le choix des oeuvres et la sélection des
interprètes
une tâche qui trouvera sa concrétisation
c'est promis début 1990